Puerto Rico is canceling a controversial
300 million dollar contract with
whitefish energy to restore power to the
island the head of Puerto Rico's power
company prepa estimates the cancellation
will now delay power restoration by 10
to 12 weeks citizens elected officials
and FEMA administrators had raised
repeated questions about that contract
they wanted to know how such a large
contract was awarded to a small Montana
company whitefish Energy says it is
disappointed by the decision David Beck
now visited the company's headquarters
in Montana he joins us now from Los
Angeles with the latest on the story
David good morning Gail good morning
when that confirmation is official it's
gonna take about 30 days to go into
effect now whitefish has already been
paid about eleven million dollars
they've billed for another ten million
and it could take an additional ten to
send all the whitefish workers back home
to the mainland so that would be about
30 million of a 300 million dollar
contract and remember while we're
talking about all this 70% of Puerto
Rico is still in the dark this morning
it's interfering with with everything
it's and it doesn't go towards the best
interest of the people of Puerto Rican
governor ricardo rosado has praised
preposition to cancel the contract with
whitefish energy but San Juan mayor
Carmen ulam Cruz who was an early and
fierce critic of the contract says it
needs to be voided entirely due to a
single clause the people of Puerto Rico
would still have to pay something called
a reasonable profit on top of everything
that they have already been charged the
outcry began after revelations that a
300 million-dollar no bid contract to
repair Puerto Rico's devastated power
grid had been awarded to Whitefish
Energy at the time of Hurricane Maria it
was said to be a two-person operation
based in Whitefish Montana the hometown
of US Interior Secretary ryan zenki
we went there looking for the company's
headquarters we found what's believed to
be the headquarters here in rural
Montana but it looks like a private
residence this two-bedroom house in a
remote area of northwestern Montana is
where the energy company calls home
after signing the deal Whitefish hired
350 workers and the company says it was
moving more than 500 line
to the island this week the head of
prepper Ricardo Ramos has defended the
300 million dollar deal and on Sunday
emphasized there was nothing illegal
about it
in a statement Whitefish said the
decision will only delay with the people
of Puerto Rico want and deserve to have
the power restored quickly there can be
no distraction whatsoever that alters of
course of action so that we can elevate
and restore our energy system in Puerto
Rico right before coming on the air we
called prepa to find out if they will be
voiding that contract and they said no
they would be cancelling it by the way
Charlie whitefish first got in contact
with Power officials in Puerto Rico
because the CEO sent a message to the
Power officials via LinkedIn thanks
David